we are indeed with Alex chabalov after a
crazy game against kaidanov Alex you are
on the back foot from the beginning in
the opening did he surprised you with
this move Bishop to F4 or were you aware
of this trend
uh on the contrary I I know this move
very well I played it with white as uh
as a recent as Chicago open uh
and uh I know exactly what why it is
looking for and uh I was looking for the
ways to avoid the standard position
after uh D6 Knight takes C6 as you can
see four yeah yeah and then I know very
well that you have to play E5 Bishop B7
Bishop B6 and at the right moment very
important to play A5 for black to not
allow white to play before uh but that
position
is really really hard to break through
especially against Gregory so I was
looking for some creative way to make it
a little bit more complicated but I
think the cost was two months
was definitely High yeah yeah
it didn't look good I mean 97 already uh
yeah well what can you do
and uh the game developed well
definitely felt like it's going White's
way he was managing to develop his
pieces while you are still struggling to
find the best place still I didn't
really see the direct way to
I think here a big moment came where he
could have played the move Bishop takes
E6 did you consider that this part yes
with ac66 and just simply defend the
pawn with Queen D3
oh really yeah just seems no I mean if
that's the way then it's it's not human
not easy
it's just like and just Bank everything
just to give up the bishop and play a
quiet move yep no yeah and then go F5 G4
G5 H5 and okay just say that I have the
attack while you don't I mean yeah I
believe you but not easy definitely not
no no no that that really didn't didn't
occur to me that that's the way but now
now I see why also B4 right if you put
it on E7 yeah no obviously yeah not not
a good one but he decided to play the
more natural C5 and two yeah here I was
more or less uh
uh I calmed down because uh you know
what doesn't have a direct attack
anymore position stabilized right yes so
so you are feeling pretty confident at
this point yeah I thought I put my
Bishop on C4 and then I'm not at the
risk to lose and then I will you know
try to
where I'm down a little bit because uh
yeah I think I I know in the game it
felt like a H5 was a he'll loosen up
himself well he gave me G5 Square for
the bishop
and um
if porn would remain on H4 I would have
trouble like activating my Bishops to
find some way to make progress yeah
but I think maybe bishop is six but six
um
still things were quite complicated
really you can not hear a I was already
like winning but uh yes I think after
after this yeah the critical more and we
had so many games uh crazy games going
on that we lost track of yours at at one
point now were there any critical
moments uh that you felt you spotted
during the game
[Music]
um
no obviously yeah I think a H5 that was
the moment when I thought that he uh
went too far yeah the pawn remained on
H4 and he makes it to move 40 it does
not allow me to activate my Bishops I
don't think black can break through
anytime soon but uh after H5 I was just
surprisingly hard to defend pawns
anymore like
the Rooks don't have too many squares
yeah to me I felt like H5 was a mistake
H5 the critical moment Alex a big
victory for you with the black pieces
now you're getting closer to those
leadership position only half a point
behind Larry and uh Dimitri guravich
yeah it's getting hot and uh military
garbage are very surprising you know
um
Factor so we'll see how he first in the
in the last two round so
uh no I'll take my chances to there we
go congratulations once again guys any
questions for Alex no just uh our our
congratulations a nice win looks like uh
well uh keep up the good work thank you
yes yes sir absolutely uh